monkey got out of there and then he
climbed up into the astronaut's arms and
he's like
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know it's been a long time since
we've talked about Mr musk in here Mr
musk hey real quick little round of
applause for Elon what are you doing
what do you do he bought Twitter oh yeah
at the original price yep yeah 44 52
maybe 50. was he upset that he had to
buy it no he wanted to right he was like
I do want to go through with it I
thought it was 44. I thought it was 52.
it's 50 something all right then it's 50
something rounded up
point of 52 per share you talking about
44 billion is what I said totally 44 is
a total not 52.80 per share yeah over
here in Wall Street 2.80 yeah 52 yeah 52
for sure okay anyways
everybody remembers
when he was doing neuralink yeah and
there were test procedures in order to
make what the [ __ ] is neurolink right
it's a [ __ ] chip that connects to
your brain 5420 for sure oh 54 20 so but
how much was the total was it 44 44
million 44 billion thank you so one of
us was right here there you go this one
well that was two dollars off you were
two dollars well I think what he was
saying is he says humans are limited in
their infinite knowledge by the
bandwidth of their thumbs you could only
that was one of the things he was saying
you can only access the internet which
is infinite knowledge through your two
thumbs so if you can go
then that's why Xbox controllers hold
you back you need to [ __ ] click with
your mouse your KD ratio is going to go
away I switched over
killing it I'm telling you dude okay
you're getting that you're [ __ ] you
didn't switch over the PC you said short
pieces I just got a keyboard and Mac uh
keyboard and mouse put a Macbook plugged
into my PS4 and I was like this real
quick this might sound weird coming from
me welcome to the master race let's go
I made it you didn't I made it it's
[ __ ] up it shouldn't sound weird but I
know that it does but it does is he
Master well there is an Ethics group I
want to be a master race the university
release Grizzly photos of monkeys who
died in neural link oh I can't watch
this do I have to see this no you don't
have to see anything there's nothing
visual nothing graphic in this article
monkeys is my favorite really positively
my favorite what kind of monkeys are
they using there's so many monkeys which
ones do you like spider monkeys I like
chimpanzees what about the finger
monkeys oh cool oh those are dope what
do you call the ones from Ace Ventura
the one with the white face hilarious
monkeys
comedian monkeys I think that's a spider
monkey is it I like all monkeys I like
monkeys wish I had a pet monkey you're
against monkeys and experiments that
make better the human race I am you
don't want monkey testing at all what
should be in place with that women yeah
just the yeah from Colleen that's gonna
give the the data solid uh statistics
put women in a suit it's not nearly as
funny
true very true it's funny it's actually
quite serious yeah it's funny but not
that funny like it's like why would a
woman be this dude I get that that's
funny yeah but like why would a monkey
be in a suit that's way
what about a banana if a woman has a
banana how's that what's she doing with
it
it's so sick I know a guy for the master
race when I see one
I don't have my headphones on I don't
have my [ __ ] gamer chair either so
easy
oh I love that [ __ ] tone of like yeah
you know what I mean
[Music]
so a university a university in
California is refusing to release a
collection of photos showing what
happened to some of the monkeys involved
in Elon musk's neural link experiments
on monkeys the Physicians committee for
responsible medicine akpcrm advocacy
group said that it has learned that the
University of California Davis is in
possession of 371 photos of the primates
that had their brains experimented on
during the neuraling tests pcrm filed a
lawsuit against your University in
February to force the university and
neuralink to reveal the true Horrors
behind their brain experiments
in the wake of the ethics group's
complaint near link admitted that a
fifth of the 23 monkeys used to test
must brain hacking implants were put
down after developing infections and
other malfunctions as per a PCR and
press release UC Davis acknowledged in
legal documents that it has 185
photographs related to necropsies
necropsy necropsies an autopsy on a
non-human creature of animals killed
during the neurolink experiments however
lawyers for the University do not want
the images made public as they claim the
public would misunderstand them well so
let's talk about [ __ ] that's safer than
neurolink apparently putting a [ __ ]
monkey in a spacesuit and shoving it
into a rocket and firing into [ __ ]
space is safer than [ __ ] Norway bro
because that monkey got out of there and
he had stories
he lived a Wonderful Life yeah
decorated life what the dog did
the dog didn't yeah the dog didn't I
know but the monkey got out of there and
then he climbed up into the astronaut's
arms and he's like
he's got stories yeah why did they have
a monkey up there they're like well we
don't want to put a person I mean we
have people granted by like they were
putting people all kinds of [ __ ] up
[ __ ] but we're like maybe this time we
should put a monkey huh that's for shits
and gigs do you feel like that's I I I'm
again hot take but as simple as that is
it's like why did they send a monkey up
there and it's like well because we
didn't want to send a person like is
that not
the basis they didn't send it alone yeah
they did by itself yeah they sent the
dog out and didn't bring it back that's
what I'm saying like the dog was way
worse they sent the monkey completely by
himself yeah they just put in a little
spacesuit the dog hurts my feeling the
dog went by itself too it didn't come
back they knew that they were sending
that dog out by itself without a return
Mission oh [ __ ] the monkey came back
that's how you Anthony's story and this
is how you see the story I'm talking
about the good news the monkey came back
he's trying to bring you up the bad news
that the Beagle didn't come home I'm
just saying the Beagle died he's like
the monkey went by itself
he was pushing buttons everywhere did
they put the beagle in a spacesuit
no they did not they did I don't think
they did I don't know I mean how did
they first test parachutes they probably
had an animal attached and pushed them
out the plane
that works yeah operation double drop
sandbag I don't know if a sandbag's
gonna survive or not but it was with
iguanas and they're expressionless but
the the weird thing about this is when
they do animal testing and it's all
pre-approved and like by law it's like
yeah go ahead you guys did all the
formal paperwork you're allowed to test
these animals putting up the photos is
another like they must get pissed when
that happens because they're like ah
come on it got approved and everything
but then people don't care they'll just
go look what you guys did and here's uh
well the argument is that this was at UC
Davis which is a public school that has
um public taxes so it's like we know
that this is a private company that
worked with um however uh the employees
that were working there or the space and
the the facility that those monkeys were
on all that stuff was public and and
taxpayers were helping to fund that
there but that's also because because
people always get mad at the wrong
people yeah like like entrepreneurs
business people whatever they play
Within the rules that are set by the
government or politicians right so if
the government says it's okay to do
research on animals
neural link is just going okay what are
the rules and then I'm going to try to
push the boundaries of these rules and a
lot of times a lot of public schools use
all the UCS and the other schools they
they work with private companies because
that's how the professors get funding so
it's a mutually beneficial like
situation it's usually a professor like
that's going hey [ __ ] Johnson and
Johnson I want to do research on
eyeballs No One's Gonna Pay me like 10
million dollars to do research on
eyeballs but Johnson and Johnson was
also trying to develop a new eye drop
might work with you on it so that's how
these relationships get formed Look No
More Tears was tested on dogs cats I'm
talking about the shampoo that does some
dogs cast on babies and then they gave
it to adults and then it's safe now we
know it's safe you can use yours have
you heard the [ __ ] like misconception
that No More Tears actually meant No
More Tears like hair wise really really
but you could put in your eyes and you
don't cry yeah someone there was like a
thing going around they were like it was
never tears it was Tears like your hair
doesn't tear but then I was like that
doesn't [ __ ] make sense yeah it
doesn't make any sense
look I I'm not picking a side pick a
side shut up don't just pick a side and
um you know
but I gotta say that for the for the
purpose of Science and forwarding the
advancement of things like technology
and our well-being our ultimate
well-being it's like nine out of 99 out
of 100 times I'd be like yeah it's gonna
probably be difficult and unfortunate
but [ __ ] if something's gonna die in
the test put it to the non-humans so for
me for me I don't even give a [ __ ] I'm
like just get mad at the right people so
like if we're if we're if we're gonna go
no more testing on animals cool that's
the new rules right or if we are going
to test on animals cool that's the new
rules if you're mad at the rules get mad
at the government same thing with like
people that are mad at gun companies
right
that's the wrong person to get mad at if
you don't want to have guns then get mad
at the government if you want to have
guns get mad at the government these
guys are just like I own a steel mill
they said we can make guns these are
pretty lucrative so I'll just start
stamping these guys so you're cool with
animal testing
like wood hinges tests like winter
parkas on a [ __ ] monkey until it dies
huh
the monkey's got he's got [ __ ] cages
winner Parker
Segway out of it did you pay the tigers
for their likeness rights on your
[ __ ] outfit you [ __ ]
gives us the Thailand sanctuary's money
are there neon Tigers
no there's not maybe we'll stop testing
there would be
but Anthony's fine Anthony's like
oh yeah make sure that that the winter
Parkers work you try it on the monkeys I
don't care you have a whale
you have a whale emblem on your head
you're literally monetizing off of
us are there cartoon whales in the wild
[Laughter]
wait explain what is being tested by
putting monkeys in Winter Parkers well
according to specifically by kinjas
according to anti-logic they have to
make sure that the Kansas Park is work
right because you can't be selling a
[ __ ] park it doesn't work we don't
sell Parkers you're looking on taobao
again you're looking at Alibaba not
Alibaba yeah I bought like seven of them
how does it result in the monkey's death
because you need parkas in Vegas no
because the monkey is gaudy trash no the
monkey is standing somewhere room temp
and they could put the Winter Park he
the monkey can't handle it and then the
scientists behind the thing is just and
like maybe the the intern is like I
don't know maybe we should maybe no no
we're going to make sure we have to see
that's Anthony talking yeah that's
that's the intern well it's probably
Mike's ongoing I think we should cut I
think we should cut it and it happens
like no no no get out of here we need
those you don't got no balls for this
[ __ ] the monkey we have to make sure
it's safe for human being testing right
so that's what you guys are doing right
yeah and then we put monkeys in
kindergles
[Music]